one of the things that happens when
let's say cohesion starts to break down
social key social cohesion is that we
instead of getting a kind of mush we get
a succession of little tyrannies I
talked about this in my video on Twitter
and the reign of chaos well today what I
want to look out look at is how that
plays into celebrity culture and also
certain things like mass shooters how is
it possible that these things come to
exist in a world of succeeding little
tyrannies of attention we could call
them
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
so what what I'm talking about here is
what we could call the tyranny of the
individual one of the things that
represents the modern age is the
individualism in which we have come to
exist that is as the purposes that we
have in common as the identities we have
in common as society stop looking
towards the same transcendent ideals the
world started to move more and more into
a kind of fragmentation and that
fragmentation is ultimately realized in
what we could call individualism that is
the notion of individuals as small
independent points you know on on a
space that aren't related together in
any discernable way the only way in
which in the world of individualism
people seem to be connected together is
as economic agents you know in terms of
their capacity to produce the capacity
to consume all of that is the last ditch
of a world that is breaking apart and it
is not sufficient it leads to some
serious diseases that we see in society
today and the problem is that we can't
desire for something more
we can't desire to heal the issues the
disease lack of meaning the fall into
nihilism the fall into drug use and you
know the the fact that we become
addicted to things like pornography and
two different drugs all of that cannot
be healed in only its manifestations the
problem is much deeper and it is the
problem of watching our common ideals
our common identities start to fragment
and so in one of my last videos I
promise you that maybe I could start
laying out more criticisms to Jordan
Peters and Jordan Jordan Peterson is my
friend and I respect a lot of the things
he says but there are many things that I
disagree with him on and this is of
course one of the things that I disagree
on I do not
that the individual is a sufficient is a
sufficient ideal in order to preserve
societies in order to to help us get out
of this
meaning crisis or this this crisis that
of Western civilization I wanted to look
at a few specific manifestations to show
how it is what it looks like when our
commonality begins to break apart now as
I mentioned before when the common ideal
the transcendent ideal starts to lose
its grip or we start to turn away from
this common transcendent ideals then
what ends up happening is not so much a
devolving into a kind of brown mush you
know like a kind of a decomposed Apple
or something like that
what although that is what happens but
what that looks like really is a let's
say a tyranny of the specific a tyranny
of the individual is that instead of us
all kind of looking towards something
which unites us what ends up happening
is in our distraction in the fact that
we've lost this common focus we start to
focus on specific things arbitrary
things start to pop up and then take up
our attention the important way to
understand it is to always remember the
strict analogy that exists between a
person as a coherent being and a society
as a coherent being as well the the the
way that a person comes together but
also the way a person fragments is
similar to the way that a society comes
together but also fragments and we can
see that as our attention as individuals
breaks apart in certain ways our
attention as society's breaks apart in
very similar ways and in ways which are
very analogical um so for example as a
person the way that our attention breaks
apart or starts to fragment is what
Christians especially Orthodox
Christians have preserved as this notion
of the passions the we have in us a bevy
of desires and these desires are not bad
in themselves they are fine if they are
let's say gathered together and held
together with a common purpose or a
common unity but as we forget that
common unity then those desires start to
pull us apart start to rip us apart and
start to appear as little tyrannies and
so we have the little tyranny of the
belly we have the little tyranny of the
eyes we have the Liril tyranny of paying
attention to gossip or you know the the
tyranny of our sexual desires as well
those things can because we've as we
forget are transcendent purpose as we
forget our common the thing that brings
us together then those individual
desires can appear to us that can
suddenly appear to us as little idols
they they they suddenly take up all of
our attention we give in to those
desires and and then all of a sudden we
we deal with the consequences afterwards
okay and so in a culture the same thing
can happen you know in a normal
traditional culture we are all let's say
worshiping together at hopefully that is
what what we're doing if not then at
least we're worshipping and logically
together that is we're not completely if
we if we're not completely separate we
at least have some things that we hold
in common
and we have an ideal societal ideal that
we hold together but as that starts to
break apart then just like a person's
passions starts to pull them apart so to
these things analogous to our passions
will start to pop up and take up our
attention in a manner which which breaks
us apart now this is exactly what
celebrity culture does if in a normal
traditional world we are turned towards
individuals
we would call them Saints Kings people
who manifest the manner in which we are
turned towards the same ideal in a
society that's breaking apart that same
desire to identify with people who show
us the direction which we're going the
same thing will happen in a society that
is breaking down and that will look like
what we call now today celebrity culture
celebrity culture the people who are
able to pop up and appear in celebrity
culture as grabbing our attention now
all of a sudden manifests the very
opposite of that unity they will
manifest things like for example being
an actor pretending to be something that
you're not now there's nothing wrong
with being an actor but the fact that
someone who pretends to be something
else
all of a sudden takes up the most
important amount of our attention is
very problematic the same with music
there's nothing wrong with music but the
fact that musicians that people who are
there to entertain us
clowns basically the fact that our
clowns have now become the top attention
grabbers in our society shows us what
direction those are going and then if
you look at what those celebrities will
manifest they will be equivalent to the
individuals passions you would say and
so people who now all of a sudden grab
attention are people who will be
excessively excessively full of pride
that will be excessively full of sexual
energy who will manifest a kind of
boastfulness a kind of excess which is
equivalent to the excesses that we
ourselves can encounter at our margins
let's say so there is this strict
analogy constant strict analogy between
the individual as a person and his or
her passions on the fringes and how a
society as it breaks down how the
individual can suddenly take up a tent
and so we end up with a very strange
world in which all of a sudden someone
who pretends to be a you know something
else for a living someone who is
basically a clown will have political
opinions that everybody thinks are
important and they will be expressing
their political opinions or their
opinions on religion or all all kinds of
things that somehow we somehow think
that that has value and that is because
as this breakdown happens these little
tyrannies pop up and one of the ultimate
examples of this has been the met the
event of the mass shooter now the mass
shooter is very much a symptom of the
this breakdown in meaning that we're
seeing because one of our let's say
desire that we have on our fringes is
this desire for violence this desire to
to show our show our strength upon
others to impose our power upon other
people this is something that we if
we're attentive to our our desires into
our thoughts we will see kind of
appearing in our fringes we usually do
it with words we usually do it by making
fun of someone by talking about someone
behind their back we do it by you know
by playing the victim in a manner which
will then give us power against the
other person we have all kinds of
strategies in which we are we try to
show our power upon others but the
ultimate version of that is of course a
violent action is of course the
possibility of ending someone else's
life and so that desire you know if we
let ourselves go to our fringe that
desire starts to manifest itself as well
and we could understand also how in a
society that desire on the fringe can be
related to war that is as something on
the fringe starts to bother has another
Empire and other people another group
attacks us or is taking our resources or
whatever then that desire will manifest
itself in order to impose our will
impose our power on the
their group whether it's to defend
ourselves or whether it is to attack
another group you know if you invade
another country that's what it is you
are you are imposing your identity your
will on that other person and so the
mass shooter becomes the individual
version of that the individual is
virtuous so the mass shooter has
everything of our culture kind of boil
down together and that is why they have
become so important and that is why they
won't be going away anytime soon no
matter what we do because they are a
symptom of a much more profound disease
of culture and so the mass shooter
because of our celebrity culture the
mass shooter ends up accomplishing what
they hope to do which is one to attain
get people's attention become the focus
of everybody's attention and they so
they become a mom a momentary Center
just like the the church in a village
traditional village is the center of the
church in a society where that breaks
down or that our Saints aren't the one
who are bringing our attention to that
which transcends us then in celebrity
culture anybody who can get that
momentary attention becomes a small
tyrannical Center for that moment is
able to impose their identity on
everybody else for a single moment and
that is what the mass shooter does if we
look at what happened in New Zealand the
New Zealand shooter we see one of the
most egregious but also the one of the
most potent examples of this happening
the shooter went so far as to tell us
what he wanted the shooter wanted for
the culture war to escalate wanted that
people start banning guns so that those
who have guns will then have to defend
themselves
he wanted to smear you know more
centrist conservative thinkers so that
people would have to take sides in the
culture war and by doing what he did he
this little center of attention this
little tyrannical Center and all of a
sudden the change that he wanted
actually happened and it is a very very
sad reality which is that the mass
shooters tend to get what they want and
they tend to accomplish that which it is
that they that they are trying to do and
our society at this moment does not have
an answer to the problem of the mass
shooter because we have completely and
fully embraced celebrity culture because
we have fully and embraced individualist
culture where we have we do not see how
we need these transcendent ideals to
bring us together because we have
embraced that culture we can fight as
much as we want the symptoms of this
problem but the the the disease is too
profound and this you can you will not
be able to get rid of the symptoms that
easily and so I know that is a bit of a
bit of a sad finish for my video but I
think it's important to understand how
serious the situation is becoming and
that although I do talk about you know
Twitter and and talk about culture we
have to understand that this breakdown
of meaning this meaning crisis in which
we are is has effects which are not
purely in terms of meaning which have
effects in everybody's life and the mass
shooter sadly has become a little
inversion of an icon for the
contemporary age if you enjoy the
symbolic world content there's a lot of
things you can do to help us out if
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends if
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
again and I will see you soon